well our members who are Healthcare
leaders across the whole system tell us
that they have never worried about a
strike as much as they're worried about
this one they think that the impact
could be really really significant and
that's as you say because it is
happening the strike itself 96 hours and
it's longer than they've experienced and
it is attached to the Easter uh weekend
and then of course the weekend after
that meaning that they're very much
expecting to see this disruption uh
happening over 10 11 days and it's a
time when quite a lot of doctors uh will
be on holiday and not necessarily able
to provide that um that that cover that
lots of the Consultants Who provided
cover last time will be having time off
in lieu and it is a really concerning
time because it's not quite clear how to
manage that level of capacity loss over
such a long period of time that's why
Healthcare leaders are working so hard
around into clock to think of
mitigations to make sure there are going
to be enough capacity and to absolutely
prioritize the most urgent care in
patient safety
well yes I want to ask you a little bit
about those mitigations but first to
what extent do you think that patient
safety could be compromised
we hear from our members that they are
concerned obviously they'll do
absolutely everything that they can to
manage patient safety but the real
concern is that it might not be enough
due to the capacity challenges that this
strike is going to cause so they have
told us that they are genuinely very
concerned about patient safety during
those strikes and that's on the minds of
every single Healthcare leader across
the country right now so what about that
mitigation how hard has it been to to
get locums in to get other doctors in to
cover these shifts
well of course everybody's doing what
they can there's a there's Consultants
there's a Specialists doctors that
pharmacists uh there's consultant nurses
there are all sorts of people within
within the healthcare structure that can
help to provide a certain level of
support but don't forget of course that
they have their own jobs and uh and that
all needs to be balanced out so really a
big part of those mitigations has
unfortunately had to be the postponing
of um of elective surgery and the
postponing of appointments which nobody
wants of course we don't we're trying so
hard to get down those waiting lists but
at the end of the day what needs to be
prioritized is urgent and emergency care
and that's why lots of people will
disappointingly be hearing that their
appointments have had to be postponed
and obviously that is a huge challenge
to even at the admin challenge to um to
postpone those and then rebook them is
huge so everybody's working as hard as
they can to reduce the risk and to
reduce the impact at some patients but I
don't think that we can fill ourselves
there will be an impact on a lot of
people here
and the two sides in this dispute the
government and the BMA seem as far apart
as ever the BMA the doctors Union are
talking about a 35 pay rise you'll know
a little bit about hospitals budgets how
realistic do you think that is
well it's not for me to say it but at
the end of the day
um it does seem that uh what what the
junior doctors are asking for and what
the government is talking about continue
to be so far apart that those
discussions do not seem to have reached
a really meaningful place and that is
what Healthcare leaders need they need
the government and the representatives
of Junior doctors to sit down and have a
genuine conversation that can work
towards a resolution and they need that
to happen urgently because this level of
disruption is incredibly concerning for
everyone in the country
well yes and there's been pretty angry
exchanges between the two sides in
recent days and weeks how disappointing
is that for you given what you've said
is at stake
it's very frustrating that they're
taking so long to come to a solution
here it's just it's not safe and it's
not in anybody's best interest to have
an ongoing stalemate in an issue that is
as important as this this is affecting
everybody who accesses Healthcare around
the country not not to mention of course
that many NHS staff themselves need to
access Healthcare and their families and
friends do so this is affecting everyone
is extremely concerning uh clearly a
solution is needed nobody who takes
industrial action does so lightly there
are genuine issues here that do need to
be resolved and we ask both sides to sit
down and have conversations that are
going to achieve that resolution